[Musique]
nous ce qui nous étonne là c'est qu'on
parle de zone de 100 contrôles
d'identité mais le contrôle d'identité
ne serait pas la seule source
éventuellement de deux contrôles de
personnes aux accidentés qui est du
contrôle au faciès terre que les
interpellations
à ce moment là il faudrait aussi prévoir
des zones sans interpellation puis ce
qu'on peut dire aussi qu'on interpelle
des gens en fonction de la couleur de
leur peau ya pas que la notion de
contrôle bien qu'ils payent à la notion
d'interpellations moi je vous le dis je
suis depuis 15 ans officier de police
judiciaire
j'ai rarement vu passer des pleins de
sous mes yeux de personnes qui viennent
porter plainte pour discrimination parce
qu'elles ont été contrôlés parce que
elle estimait qu'elle avait été contrôlé
par couleur de peau j'ai subi des
contrôles au faciès
la réponse qui était donné à savoir que
les gens viennent pas se plaindre
évidemment ils vont passer à vos pelles
la police sauf que en plein ne seront
pas acceptés ni reçu on le voit
régulièrement fin t2 quand même être
après sérieux là dessus ensuite oui les
contrôles au faciès c'est pas compliqué
vous voyez à bronzer
on parle de présupposés qu'il est
potentiellement délinquants d'avoir la
question du contrôle d'identité n'est
pas obligatoire n'est pas obligatoire en
france c'est un jeune chose sonne ne
savent pas c'est qu'en vérité on peut
produire quand on est citoyen français
une cliente et qui est pas forcément qui
est pas forcément la carte d'identité ça
peut être que permis ça peut être ça
peut être n'importe quel autre document
est effectivement la question qui se
pose en termes de droit extrêmement
importante c'est de savoir est-ce que
vous l'union avec les crises qu'on a
traversé g par la crise ça fait 30 ans
qu'on parle de contrôle au faciès est ce
que vous mais non on doit trouver une
alternative ou une solution pour régler
cette question
je pense que oui estimé qu'il faut
revoir la politique du contrôle
d'identité
pour l'instant il ya des législateurs en
france ils font la loi
si vraiment ça avait été un scandale
depuis je sais pas depuis trente ans
qu'on entend ce rôle freins et bien
j'imagine qu'il ya quand même eu des
partis politiques successives
d'obédiences différentes qui se sont
succédé et je pense que si ça avait été
un chantier majeur du lien
police-population il aurait été pris en
main par la gauche la droite le centre
ou le milieu est vieux qu'on pu
contrôler quasiment le délit de jeunesse
et d'immigration existe ensuite la
question qui se pose c'est de savoir
pourquoi est ce que les politiques n'ont
pas agi parce que c'est un corps
constituée qui est le bras armé entre
guillemets de l'état qui garantit la
sécurité évidemment que les hommes
politiques quels que soient leur
obédience ont pas revenir là dessus et
je rappelle quand même que l'information
coloniaux terre il n'y a pas de carte
d'identité aux états unis n'y a pas de
carte d'identité et les pays où il n'a
pas besoin de contrôles d'identité au
contrôle le comportement des personnes
lorsqu'elle connaît adélie pas quand on
supposé on présuppose que cette dernière
commet un délit
donc la question qui se pose aujourd'hui
c'est de savoir ce que oui ou non ce
contrôle est nécessaire et ce contrôle
facile question est acceptable la
réponse est non moi je dis que le
policier devra avoir une caméra comment
enclencher sur lui et cash à terre à
chaque interpellation qu'ont pu lui-même
soit protégé d'accusations sans doute
parfois palacios d'autrefois réel qu'on
sache qui se passe je dire on est au
siècle de la caméra tout le monde des
caméras sur lui haute définition
on n'est pas en mesure de produire des
éléments de preuve à la caméra lors
d'une interpellation qui se passerait
bien ou mal s'il faisait ce policier ce
travail là il s'est arrêté au rôle en
tant que les policiers sont inquiets
d'être filmés ou de films et c'est là où
de se poser la question pourquoi est ce
vrai que puisqu'ils sont les porteurs de
l'ordre républicain et de la loi et là
je alors les policiers nationaux que je
représente sont très largement pour la
caméra tétons puisqu'ils savent très
bien que d'une salle et protège en
intervention lorsqu'ils sont victimes de
violence et litrage ou de rébellion ça
permet de 4,2 comme aux dires de
démontrer les faits et les procurent de
république qui instruit cette affaire
nous demandent systématiquement pendant
les phases de la vue des images que ce
soit de la vidéoprotection où les
caméras piétons pour montrer les actes
d'hostilité ou de blé ou de violence de
d'un tiers vis-à-vis de la police
il faut savoir que madame et dont a pris
position contre les caméras piétons
contre les drones est contre la loi de
sécurité globale il faut faire très
attention au retraitement pas seulement
l'information recrutement et la qualité
la formation et la psychologie des gens
qui reçoivent une arme comme celle là
parce qu'ils ont un pouvoir absolu sur
la population sont pas de simples
fonctionnaires ils ont le pouvoir de vie
et de mort lorsqu'il parce que ça se
passe mal donc ça c'est une question
dispose la formation doit être révisée
et il faut surtout des pistes et des
policiers qui ont des tendances racistes
qui édite aussi il n'y a pas de souci
non plus de se pencher sur la formation
mais on va toujours arriver aux mêmes
eaux mais l'écueil c'est à dire les
clients est-ce qu'on a les finances pour
de nouveau rallongés la formation pour
de nouveau
ouvrir des écoles de police qui ont été
fermés malheureusement c'est le serpent
qui se mord la queue